The other shoe dropped for me then because you know,
you're,
you're talking about that at least in part,
you're talking about that ecstatic experience as the,
as the necessary counter position to isolation and abandonment,
loneliness and all of those things,
which,
which I think is a very,
a very reasonable way of thinking about it.
It's like meaning as the antidote to isolation and Tra and tragedy and
malevolence for that matter.
And I think music is,
you know,
I've thought deeply about music.
I've,
I've tried to figure out why it has,
what it represents and why it has the effects that it has.
And I think,
and this is a neuroscientific few of it to some degree,
and you know,
it seems to me that it's better to think about the world as con as something
that consists of patterns rather than as something that consists of objects.
So it object would actually be a pattern that sustains itself across time.
It's it,
that's not all that very,
very good insight.
You get applause for that.
Thank you.
And so,
so then you think,
well for you,
you can even think about the way the visual system works this way.
So you know,
we tend to think that there's a world out there and then there's an image of
that world projected onto our retina and then the images is reconstructed,
say in our visual cortex.
And then we,
uh,
then we can become conscious of that image and planner actions in,
in a,
in consequence of that.
But that isn't how it works.
The way it works is that there are patterns in the world and then the patterns
are shifted into patterns of light of illumination.
And then those are shifted into patterns of neural activity on the retina.
And then those are shifted into patterns of neural conductance,
the law,
the optical nerves,
and then patterns in the visual cortex.
And then those are expressed as patterns of movement.
So it's all the transformations of patterns and the meaning of a visual
perception is the pattern of action that it gives rise to,
which is why you need a body meant to be able to perceive.
And I think the reason that music speaks so deeply to us of fundamental meaning
is because it's actually the most representative art form.
You know,
because people think about it in some senses,
the least representative art form,
I don't think that's right at all.
I think it represents the reality that exists in a profound sense beyond what
our census revealed to us moment to moment.
And so it puts people then when you're moving to the music and we were all
moving to the music,
or when you're dancing,
let's say with someone else and you're,
and you're as pairs and you're all dancing together,
it's that the patterns of the cosmos,
so to speak,
manifesting themselves as the patterns of the music manifesting themselves as
the patterns of your body and in syncopation with everyone else.
So it's also a symbolic representation of a harmonious,
an ideal society.
And there it is something that's beyond us.
And so it's,
it's interests.
So I get it.
So,
so partly what you're saying,
if I understand you,
is that for you,
the,
the ecstatic collective that was associated with music,
for example,
in pop music perhaps was you could see it out very clearly as the antidote to
painful isolation.
And,
and I mean,
one of the things that struck me as,
as,
as struck me as near miraculous about music,
especially in the rather nihilistic and atheistic society,
is that it really does fill the void that was left by the death of God.
And it's partly because you cannot rationally critique music.
You know,
it speaks to you,
it speaks of meaning.
And no matter what you say about it,
no matter how cynical you are,
you cannot put a crowbar underneath that and lifted up and,
and,
and toss it aside.
And music was so,
such a powerful cultural force in the 60s and the 70s and it's like
overwhelmingly powerful force.